ah
[Música]
ustedes piensan que todos los políticos
nos dicen la verdad
miremos estos tres ejemplos todos
conocemos a estas personas el presidente
de la república tabaré vázquez el líder
de la oposición luis lacalle pou y el
líder del partido del agente edgardo
novica y muchas muchas veces los hemos
escuchado decir cosas como estas
tabaré vázquez el tabaco mata año a año
a más personas que lo que mataron las
dos guerras mundiales juntas
luis lacalle pou hace que es la
mutualista del estado del proveedor de
salud del estado desde la reforma hasta
la actualidad perdió un 20% de usuarios
no vi que en salto se calcula que hay
más de un 20% de gente sin trabajo
y ustedes que creen que estas
afirmaciones son verdaderas
no las tres afirmaciones son falsas y
miremos porque en el primer caso según
la organización mundial de la salud por
año fallecen alrededor de 7 millones de
personas por consumo o exposición a
tabaco mientras que los conteos
históricos hablan de que en las dos
guerras mundiales fallecieron algo así
como 60 millones de personas
en el segundo caso según datos del
propio sistema nacional de salud desde
la reforma que fue en 2007 hasta la
actualidad el organismo perdió un 4% de
usuarios y no un 20
y en el último caso según el instituto
nacional de estadísticas que es el único
organismo que mide el desempleo en
uruguay en salto actualmente hay un 9.9
por ciento de desempleo y no un 20
ahora cuántos de nosotros escuchamos
cosas como estas y dudamos cuántos vamos
a el ine o a cualquier otro organismo
productor de datos y nos ponemos a
fijarnos y esas cosas son realmente así
es cierto no es tan fácil los costos de
informarse son altos son altos en tiempo
porque hay que sentarse a buscar
información a leer informes a buscar
documentos son altos en conocimientos
porque hay que saber leer esas
estadísticas leer esos documentos
incluso hay que saber dónde ir a
buscarlos pero igual en general nuestra
actitud es más bien pasiva cuántas veces
escuchamos a un político x decir un dato
como este y nos cuestionamos si eso será
realmente así
nosotros en widgets siempre nos
cuestionamos si esas cosas son realmente
así widget es un proyecto de una
organización de la sociedad civil que se
dedica a la verificación del discurso
público en uruguay esto significa que
nos dedicamos a corroborar si estas
frases y otras tantas frases son
correctas tenemos una metodología
rigurosa y siete calificaciones que van
desde lo más verdadero a lo más falso
hoy en día somos el único sitio que se
dedica a esta tarea en uruguay pero no
estamos solos en el mundo se calcula que
alrededor de 150 sitios que se dedican a
la verificación del discurso público a
nivel mundial hay incluso sitios así en
países donde la libertad de expresión o
los derechos políticos no están
garantizados para que vean qué
importante qué es
y ya que prestamos atención nosotros
cuando estamos verificando ya qué cosas
pueden prestar atención ustedes cuando
escuchan un discurso
primero prestamos atención a quien dice
lo que dice y por qué que se sostiene
esa persona está argumentando a favor o
en contra de ese tema
segundo prestamos atención a los números
a las cifras a los porcentajes a las
estadísticas a los promedios en general
esas cosas no son tan difíciles de
verificar y hay muchos sitios en uruguay
y en el mundo donde pueden ir a buscar
esos datos
y tercero nos fijamos en las
comparaciones siempre que se nos compara
con otros países con otras ciudades
porque se elige en esos casos si
nosotros ese fenómeno que se está
hablando es igual en este otro lugar que
acá y por lo tanto se mide igual y es
estrictamente comparables
y por último prestamos atención al
tiempo estamos hablando de hoy con
cifras de hace 2 35 años es estable eso
en el tiempo o sea no cambia o si cambia
y capas hay mejores datos a los que
podemos acudir
para qué
entonces más allá de estos detalles cuál
es la idea atrás de widget la idea es
entender la diferencia entre ustedes que
están sentados acá delante y el resto
ustedes acá delante me ven con otros
ojos por así decirlo ven que tengo un
aparatito para cambiar la diapositiva
ven que tengo una pantalla donde las van
pasando ver mis movimientos completos y
mis expresiones nerviosas mucho más de
cerca y por lo tanto pueden juzgar mejor
lo que estoy diciendo
sin embargo los que están hacia atrás no
tanto me ven a la distancia chiquitas
capas que no me ven completa
y me ven imparcial no ven mis
herramientas o mis movimientos
esa diferencia justamente sobre lo que
nosotros queremos concientizar
estamos muy acostumbrados a los del
fondo lo que refiere al discurso público
estamos muy acostumbrados a dar lo
parcial lejano así nomás
pero qué tipo de decisiones vamos a
tomar si somos los del fondo el año que
viene sin ir más lejos cuando nos
enfrentemos a una nueva elección aunque
información con qué herramientas con qué
conocimiento vamos a elegir en
definitiva qué tipo de ciudadanos vamos
a hacer
mi invitación es a que se vengan hacia
adelante a que observen de cerca el
discurso público ya que cuestionen a que
cuestiona lo que dicen los políticos
tanto los que no van a votar como los
que sí van a votar que cuestionan lo que
dicen los medios de comunicación y los
periodistas para que cuestionen incluso
lo que dice widget o lo que les digo yo
hoy acá no necesariamente esperando que
todo sea mentira o que todo es una
equivocación pero sí diciendo a sectores
activos de la información y teniendo
conciencia crítica sobre lo que leen o
escuchan mi invitación es entonces a que
sean ciudadanos de primera fila muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah